[Music]
it begins
with a countdown on august 14th
1947 a woman in bombay goes into labor
as the clock ticks towards midnight
across india people hold their breath
for the declaration of independence
after nearly two centuries of british
occupation and rule
and at the stroke of midnight a
squirming
infant and two new nations are born
in perfect synchronicity these events
form the foundation of midnight's
children
a dazzling novel by the british indian
author
salman rushdie the baby who is the exact
same age as the nation is saleem cyanide
the novel's protagonist his narrative
stretches over 30 years of his life
jumping backwards and forwards in time
to speculate on family secrets
and deep-seated mysteries these include
the greatest enigma of all
salim has magic powers and they're
somehow related to the time of his birth
and he's not the only one all children
born
in and around the stroke of midnight are
imbued with extraordinary powers
like parvati the witch a spectacular
conjurer
and salim's nemesis shiva a gifted
warrior
with his powers of telepathy salim
forges connections with a vast network
of the children of midnight
including a figure who can step through
time and mirrors
a child who changes their gender when
immersed in water
and multilingual conjoined twins
salim acts as a delightful guide to
magical happenings
and historical context alike
although his birthday is a day of
celebration
it also marks a turbulent period in
indian history
in 1948 the leader of the indian
independence movement
mahatma gandhi was assassinated
independence
also coincided with partition which
divided british-controlled india
into the two nations of india and
pakistan
this contributed to the outbreak of the
indo-pakistani wars
in 1965 and 1971.
salim touches on all this and more
tracing the establishment of bangladesh
in 1971 and the emergency rule
of indira gandhi this vast historical
frame
is one reason why midnight's children is
considered one of the most illuminating
works of post-colonial literature
ever written this genre typically
addresses the experience of people
living in colonised
and formerly colonized countries and
explores the fallout
through themes like revolution migration
and identity rashti who
like salim was born in 1947 was educated
in
india and britain and is renowned for
his cross-continental histories
political commentary and magical realism
he enriches midnight's children with a
plethora of
indian and pakistani cultural references
from family traditions to food religion
and folk tales scribbling by night
under the watchful eyes of his lover
padma
saleem's frame narrative echoes that of
a thousand and one nights
where a woman named shaharazad tells her
king
a series of stories to keep herself
alive and as salim
sees it a thousand and one is the number
of night
of magic of alternative realities
over the course of the novel rushdie
dazzles us with multiple versions of
reality
sometimes this is like reading a roller
coaster
saleem narrates who what
am i my answer i am everyone
everything whose being in the world
affected
was affected by mine i am anything that
happens after i've gone
which would not have happened if i had
not come
nor am i particularly exceptional in
this matter each eye
every one of the now 600 million plus of
us
contains a similar multitude i repeat
for the last time to understand me
you'll have to swallow a world
salim's narrative often has a breathless
quality
and even as rushdie depicts the
cosmological consequences of a life
he questions the idea that we can ever
condense history
into a single narrative his mind-bending
plot
and shape-shifting characters have
garnered continuing fascination
and praise not only did midnight's
children
win the prestigious man booker prize in
his year of publication
but in a 2008 competition that pitted
all 39 winners against each other
it was named the best of all the winners
in a masterpiece of epic proportions
rushdie reveals that there are no
singular truths rather it's wiser to
believe in several versions of reality
at once
hold many lives in the palms of our
hands
and experience multiple moments in a
single stroke of the clock
wondering what you should read next pick
a good page turner
with this playlist
you